after a decade in the shadows of his
predecessor
mohammed bazum emerged as niger's fifth
democratically elected president
the day was also a historic one for the
country
it marked the first peaceful transition
of power from one civilian government
to another the ceremony was overshadowed
by a recent failed coup
and rising attacks by armed groups along
its borders
factors many here hope he will use his
experience
as former head of both the foreign and
interior ministries
to resolve licensing security
the most important is security people of
niger are desperate for security
second to that is good governance and
finally equity and justice
but above all the depoliticalisation of
governance which is very important
we hope the president will appoint the
right people in the right positions
devoid of partisanship but some believe
that niger politics and politicians will
limit his ability to deliver real change
for bazoom mohammed the hard work begins
now he will need to unite a deeply
divided nation
whose stability is once again threatened
by wednesday's
failed coup but the president can count
on global support
judging from reactions on the failed
coup however the biggest challenge
to his presidency is not only having to
deal
with ambitious military officers but
also
the threat posed by boko haram and armed
groups based in neighboring mali
a reality not lost on mr bazum as he
rose to give his first address as
president
for a long time the criminals of the
islamic state and the greater sahara who
are affiliated to daesh
almost exclusively attacked the defense
and security forces
but for some time they've begun to
attack village chiefs
and then progressively civilians in an
indiscriminate manner
since last january they've been carrying
out massacres of innocent civilians on a
large scale
thereby committing war crimes terrorism
is a misfortune for our country
for his predecessor mohammed isafo it
was a moment of fulfillment offering
democratic hope
for much of the country though the joy
of this day will only be shared
if muhammad bazoom is able to bring
stability and development in asia
ahmed idris al-jazeera near me